[Music]
stanford university
today's class session is on resource
technology innovations addressing
climate change and resource scarcity i'm
excited that we have tom and john here
today since they both know that they're
my two favorite people when it comes to
leaders addressing our society's big
challenge of climate change john wine's
the professor at stanford he's also
director of the energy modeling forum as
well as deputy director of the precor
institute at stanford he was also a lead
author of the ipcc report that led him
to be recognized for the 2007 nobel
peace prize and he's also been honored
for his contributions to the california
air resources board for his work on ab32
tom is an absolute icon in silicon
valley he's started various venture
funds and has invested in many
significant companies since the 1980s
he's currently the managing director of
baruch future ventures he previously
founded the venture funds formation
eight as well as cmea capital he was a
founding member of obama's national
advisory council on innovation
entrepreneurship and he's also an
advisor to just a number of initiatives
including breakthrough energy ventures
a few years ago john and i authored a
book titled renewed energy of which tom
was featured in a chapter of it um so
yeah i'm excited to have both of you
here today we'll go ahead and get
started with a few questions i thought
it would be useful to frame the
conversation of climate change around a
few key resources that are fundamental
and essential for human survival and for
preserving and expanding life and these
include food water air and shelter
and just discussing those resources and
innovations around them and issues we
need to consider as well first question
i have is in terms of
climate change and the connection
between climate change and its impact on
resource
scarcity john could you help us clarify
what is the connection between climate
change and its impact on resource
scarcity
that's a really um huge and complicated
question but i'll do my best to be brief
i guess i'll i'll give a little a little
bit in the order in which i learned it
so obviously changes in climate affect
outdoor activities of great importance
like agriculture forestry they have an
impact on what is typically termed
unmanaged ecosystems managed in
unmanaged forests so there are major
connections there they actually go a
little bit in both directions but mostly
bad could lead to a tipping point we now
have a situation where
of the greenhouse gases emitted about
half stay in the atmosphere
about a quarter i for i'm not even up on
the most recent debate about whether a
quarter or more goes into the ocean and
a quarter or more goes into
growing things because plants take in
oxygen
sorry take in carbon
dioxide and exhale oxygen the opposite
of living of humans and animals so that
was the first first thing and then i got
into the climate game on the energy
systems mitigation side so that's taken
me now 25 30 years to
look into that and work with various
groups including several ipcc rounds on
what we might be able to do on that side
at the same time i've been uh
consistently drawn back into the
impact side so now we know it's not just
about growing things but
these changes in climate can affect
human health directly and indirectly
they can affect the way we use land
water and energy through the corn cycle
effect they actually make the thermal
power plants more less efficient
increases in temperature also cause
problems with thermal pollution and
waterways so there are epa restrictions
on that which could cause power uh
plants to be shut down and more recently
but perhaps importantly a whole host of
things that are more in the extreme
event category namely flooding coastal
zone damage droughts and
more recently wildfires here across the
west coast so we're now actively trying
to figure out what goes on what causes
it i wouldn't say all the impacts are
completely attributable to climate
change but the balance of evidence
suggests a great a great share of what's
gone on has been pretty easily
attributable to climate change sorry to
be so long-winded and tom i mentioned
air food water and shelter as for
critical resources how do you think
about investing in those areas and
driving innovation in those areas yeah i
i think
you omitted one
factor and that's energy of course
embedded in all the other four that you
did mention including shelter when you
but
when you think about innovating in those
areas i generally think mostly in power
law terms
and
how we can take advantage of
two of the greatest
inventions in the history of humankind
one
the semiconductor and the other is the
discovery at the end remarkably those
two events occurred within a few years
of each other in the period of 1947 to
after one of the worst centuries of
lumen's existence and ever since that
time we've been able to adopt these
exponential technologies power law
technologies
to
creating technology
driven change where we
find the most fruitful outcomes is in
the intersection of multiple technology
so we spend a lot of our time in biology
in information technology and materials
science
picture a venn diagram of those
disciplines and look for the sweet spot
and you will be able to identify an
opportunity
to change the way
things are done
and to change the way people think about
things and we have many examples
that i could recite but that would take
the rest of this
session so let's leave it at that for
now
i was getting excited to also dive into
some of these examples later today tom
what motivated you to address the
problem of climate change and resource
scarcity in the first place i think it
was just that it was it was the parallel
aspects of climate change see
like the emoji
slapping in the head it just becomes so
obvious that
one thing just always leads to another
and so there are the
edge that we're living on right now
is so sensitive
and as we continue to dump co2 into the
atmosphere
and continue to practice other
unacceptable and
environmental
practices we're just
pushing over the tipping point and we're
pushing it at a faster rate
because obviously
global warming is one consequence of
focus but
there are many other consequences as
we've seen recently for example in the
melting of the polar ice caps suddenly
you know it's a huge concern about
methane
bearing seed all that methane has been
encased
in ice once that ice melts
methane is 84 times more powerful of
greenhouse gas with co2
so we have to deal not only with co2 we
have to deal with methane we have to
deal with the exponential consequences
of
the actions that we're taking as humans
and that's what's so scary
but at the same time we've been blessed
with the power law
disciplines that i talked about earlier
and their intersections of those
disciplines as a means of addressing and
i don't want to say that technology is
the only solution it certainly is not
there there are many others that are
more behavioral in nature and
regulatory and otherwise what about you
john why it motivated you to address the
problem uh so uh interestingly i think
this optimism about technology is
something tom and i definitely share
even more interestingly i actually grew
up about
five or ten miles from murray new jersey
so as a little kid i heard all the
legendary stories about the invention of
the transistor at bell labs back at that
point i would say for me i think
ernestine knows this backstory on me i
grew up in the age of
sputnik and wanted to do something with
my somewhat limited analytic skills as a
kid which i didn't screw up and still
have a little bit of today to solve big
societal problems so that was always my
motivation so i started with aerospace i
was the originally aero astro guy trying
to win the race to space and ultimately
the co-worker got involved early
in my 20s at a well-known pentagon think
tank on national security trying to
think about nuclear arms control race to
space even using r d as a competitive
thing against the uh
other dominant stupid superpower at that
point and then fortunately for me in a
way my iran group and i both thought of
energy environment as being the next big
or among the next big set of societal
challenges we were
and then morphed into
oil security for a while which did have
a technological edge but many other
geopolitical edges and so on and then by
the early 90s it looked like the big new
challenge for the day maybe a bigger one
than all the other energy ones at least
in resource ones was climate change and
a friend of mine said you ought to
switch completely into climate change
and climate change analyses and i
thought he was crazy for about a year
and then as information emerged and i
got more knowledgeable i said by by
golly i think you're right so that's
really
how i got into climate change and once i
got into it it's been hard i still do a
few other things but it's dominated my
life for the last 25 years at least i
want to dive into air specifically one
of the resources i mentioned and john
could you clarify what is
the cause of industrial air pollution
for instance tom briefly alluded to
methane and co2 but what has caused the
massive air quality problem that we face
today
so most of it is combustion of fossil
fuels the commercial ones oil gas and
particularly coal that produces not just
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases but a
range of what epa calls criteria
pollutants when i was a kid we didn't
have criteria pollutants and we didn't
know
it was there i remember going to my
summer internship even then in socal
and you could barely see anything none
of the buildings as i drove in the end
of my
uh journey and by then even then this is
in the late 1970s early 1980s they had
gotten all of the oil refineries and
power plants out of the la basin uh and
a guy actually got very famous a
well-known atmospheric chemistry saying
maybe it's the cars
so the cars actually produced a lot of
the pollutants and nitrous oxide
some particles and whatnot and as we now
know those are among the most critically
evaluated air pollutants but just to
give you an updated global perspective
the world health organization through
the global burden of disease study
attributes around 7 million deaths a
year
to particle pollution about half indoor
and half outdoor so the indoor type is
largely in developing regions where they
have cook stoves that work on twigs and
cow dung
and they seal up their dwellings and get
really bad they get rid of all the
insects and the food tastes good but in
fact they also suffer
a dire health consequences in our part
of the world it is mostly these coal and
other emissions say and develop china
and major cities in the u.s for the last
30 or 40 years we've gotten more and
more of a handle on how many premadera
deaths and other health impacts have
come from pollutants largely associated
with the same
some of the same fossil fuels that cause
climate change tom i know you're an
investor in um some companies that are
tackling our air quality problems such
as mosaic materials and wind could you
share more about new processes that
you've seen that can make an impact on
global co2 emissions and doing that
while simultaneously lowering energy
costs yeah i think in thinking about
emissions you have to think about
those that are
obvious and insidious
and those that are just insidious the
obvious insidious of
ones that john mentioned co2 and methane
but then that's only the beginning of
the list
and not only do you have to be concerned
about species but you have to be
concerned about particle size
because those kinds of emissions that
are smaller than say two and a half
microns
actually can be absorbed by our bodies
through the logs can create huge kinds
of healthcare problems such as the ones
that that john was referring to so
this is a real multi-body
problem not easily solvable we found
that the most effective means we found
so far are those separations
technologies or sensor technologies that
can
eliminate the very fine particles but
that's probably a good place to start
but then when we move over and and then
there's mercury other emissions from
coal-fired fire
power plants which are
usually trace elements in in coal
but there also trace
many trace elements in oil and gas as
well we have to be concerned about all
that there's been a lot of progress made
in
the us and
various kinds of scrubbing techniques
associated with industrial processes
but those kind of regulations don't
exist in much of the third world so
and we all live on one planet so we have
to deal with that but i i think the
another very insidious aspect of all
this is covet 19 and other kinds of
contaminants and viral particles that
exist in the atmosphere that's one of
one of the aspects that that our
portfolio company wind is addressing
that you mentioned but it's the other
aspect is then
the obvious and insidious so that's the
co2 and methane primarily that
contributes to global warming and and
that's a whole separate subject any
other thoughts um from either of you in
terms of our air quality problem and
what we need to do to address that
before we move on to the next resource
that i'd like to talk about i think
there's been a lot of discussion about
this whole subject of co2 emissions and
methane emissions primarily co2
everybody
by now i think knows the numbers
417 parts per million
increasing at a rate of one to two parts
per million
between now and 2050 goal of
breakthrough
energy is to identify enough new
technologies to apply to reduce that to
zero by
2050.
frankly i don't think that's good enough
but at least it's the place to start and
i think that
the
solutions to the whole co2
problem can be found not only in
technologies
but also in innovative business models
and and financial fintech
i'd see innovative business models and
fintech as an opportunity to change
people's behavior which
everybody says you can't do
but then i see it happening all the time
so you can change people's behavior
you have to give them a little push
sometimes that comes from an innovative
business or
financial technology we can do a lot and
we're not the fact is we're not doing
enough until we get to zero and then
start restoring the
atmosphere
we haven't done it on so talking about
food security as a resource john
question for you is could you clarify
the relationship between climate change
and today's food security crisis what
are the factors contributing to our food
security crisis again quite a complex
set of interrelationships i already
mentioned that climate change could
increase productivity of agricultural
pops for a while but ultimately they're
all going to go down i have some econ
colleagues who say all you have to do is
switch different crops and i have a
feeling the they think it's reasonable
to expect the whole row will be living
off bananas or other crops like that and
then as temperatures get too warm for
even them to grow any place what are you
going to do so i think that's where we
started this if you look at more detail
in the how we use land and whatnot a big
surprise to me even the last 10 years
has been
the extent to which a lot of land is
used for beef production
and very uh inefficiently so in brazil
we had a great burning down of
rainforest to
create posture pastures and also more
recently grow fairly inefficient forms
of bile crops and in the need to go very
low people have now reanalyzed this and
recognized that brazil takes about twice
as much land to grow ahead of cattle
within the developed world and
ecologists have now gone out and figured
out that you probably could reclaim that
land which would be a great boon for a
climate because you could either grow
trees or
advanced biofuels were more crops there
that's where where the rubber beats the
road there are lots of emissions from
the arc sector there's again methane
emissions from
bovine cattle and and goats those are
remarkably large numbers that people
don't fully uh realize now the other
thing that's there are two other things
at the macro scale that are important
and that is agricultural productivity
we've lived on the earth trying to
sustain a ever-growing population by
higher productivity more crops per unit
area sometimes doing that with nitrous
nitrogen fertilizers which may be bad
for air and water pollution but also for
climate change some of the scarier
scenarios i've seen as the rest of the
world becomes like the meteors
of the world and that leads to a lot
more emissions and a lot more land use
as well as being not so good for our
health personally so i think that's a
new frontier on the tom baruch side some
of the more interesting schemes i've
seen for innovative cross-cut
technologies would provide both say
micro algebra algae for energy and
possibly he can tell you more than i can
low-cost ways of protein that you could
actually find the land to grow because
they might be on the coast or even in in
the ocean
so i think there's quite a strong set of
interactions in both directions between
the climate system and the agriculture
activities and food supply tom john just
alluded to some of the innovations that
you're possibly investing in and looking
at to address the problem of food
security could you share more about that
i know you're an investor in companies
that are looking at for instance beef
production was mentioned so blue nest
beef is one of your investments kalista
as another and just in general your
thoughts on what we need to do to ensure
food security and sustainable
agriculture do we have until midnight or
lager maybe a few uh
yeah it's a tough problem but very
simply we can what i find amazing is
john's talking about the destruction of
the rainforest in brazil
and a lot of that destruction is
actually
being done
in order to use the land
to grow soy which then is being used to
make impossible burgers i feel like
we're in the shakespeare play now tom
so i'm a great proponent of synthetic
protein and the doorway to synthetic
protein is exactly in the intersection
of technologies that i talked about
earlier and that's in the intersection
of biology and information technology
there are a number of companies
addressing the opportunity to make
essentially make protein from dna and
it's not
terribly far from reality the company
you mentioned callista
is a company that's making
protein by using methane as a feedstock
so we combine methane and
oxygen and a few other relatively
available elements in a way
and use a biological catalyst we call
the methanotroph
which can enable us to convert these
elements into amino acids and proteins
but kalista has a
multi-tiered market approach beginning
initially with
using synthetic protein to feed
fish that are raised on aqua farms today
about 50
of carnivorous
fish like salmon are raised on aqua
farms mostly in
in and around the north sea
and currently they're being fed
anchovies that are harvested off the
coast of chile and shipped in freighters
to the north sea
and
we can eliminate all of that the fuel
involved we can eliminate some methane
not a lot but some but more importantly
if you look at the these there's the
logistics aspects of all this is really
important oil company oil and gas
companies have known that for hundreds
of years
because oil and gas is often found in
places where it can't be used
so the issue about is how do you get
downstream to customers and
what covet 19 has done is exposed the
fragility of our supply chains
and if you look at meat for example
what happened during the worst parts of
the pandemic all the value-added meat
functions were shut down the world today
depends on meat from primarily argentina
brazil and the u.s
and that's it
and the supply chain is ugly anybody
who's seen much of what goes on in the
cattle yards in chicago knows what
that's all about we can we eliminate all
of that with synthetic protein we can
make protein available
any place where there's methane and
unfortunately there's too much methane
as it is uh price of methane now is
almost it's almost free and this is one
of the
primary business aspects that we look at
is energy has become free relatively
pure water is
can be now derived at very low cost
and we can make protein cheaply and we
can make it
where we consume it and so we totally
take out our dependency supply chains
add on certain big companies like
cargill who we really don't need anymore
i don't think anybody be bothered by st
cargill disappear there's again
other examples of what we can do with
synthetic biology and our
ability to
tip the scales in the other direction
in terms of climate change i want to
talk about water treatment and
conservation next tom i'm going to hand
it back to you in terms of the idea that
during water treatment one of the ideal
solutions is having zero liquid
discharge so that's where all water is
recovered and contaminants are reduced
to solid waste
when can we get to that point do you
have any thoughts on that and in general
how we can provide access to clean water
in the future
yeah of course when we
and actually the new bill gates book how
to avoid a climate disaster he talks
about water there are
5 billion people
probably
60 to 75 percent of global population
will
be
without
adequate supplies of water due to
climate change that's a very direct
impact of climate change growth and even
as we turn more of
north africa and europe into desert
then we're only accentuating the water
problem there's another aspect of water
that i think is interesting and that is
again back to supply chain today water
is
generally harvested several hundred
miles from the destination where it's
used
we use an enormous amount of energy to
move water i've seen estimates that in
california 20 to 30 of our energy
consumption is simply to move water so
we're moving water from the sierras
to san francisco
palo alto
etc southern california and the
opportunity here with again with
technology is to be able to democratize
those supply chains so we talk about
democratizing food supply chain
protein we can do the same thing with
water so source water is our source
global is
a company that we're involved with
that's harvesting water from the
atmosphere we can work in environments
where humidity ranges from 10 to 90
percent and
the water
is derived on your rooftop because we
use solar energy to purify the water
pretty amazing we can produce water for
one to two cents a liter
and it's the same quality that you would
pay two dollars a liter for if you buy
it at the nearest convenience store so
still more expensive than municipal
water
but
in certain regions of the world
people
will pay more for clean water especially
very pure water which is what source
water is we're working with another
company that is in
come up with a
wave energy approach so
the source water approach uses solar
energy which is a release to zero in the
case of the the other startup that we
recently invested in we use wave energy
as a means of desalinating water so we
can make water available to
any oceanfront region in the world and
that's where most people live and
actually
the cost associated with using wave
energy is actually
less than a huge desalination plant
would cost again and you have to
remember this is not just about material
science and membranes and
it's also about energy and and taking
advantage of free energy
such as we get from the sun the wind and
and then when combined with technologies
like synthetic biology
there's no really no reason that we will
ever need to use oil again for anything
no i'm convinced for that that by itself
will solve
the whole climate problem but that's a
little way pollyannish but the point is
that we have the tools
what we often lack is
sometimes the will has to be voted by
the regulatory side of things
and the financial side we see today a
huge movement toward esg investing
environmental social governance
but it's mostly about environmental it's
we call it esg but it's mostly ens and
the fact is that financial institutions
are putting their weight behind
trillions of dollars of investment
including organizations like blackrock
which manages five trillion dollars so
this is happening this is a great
opportunity for affecting climate but
again it's not all on technology
we need a movement such as the esg
movement there's such as the regulatory
movements
and then we can start moving the needle
john any other thoughts in terms of
access to clean water the problem of
economic or physical water scarcity and
what we should be doing to address this
there's a lot more monitoring that we
should and could do one thing we found
in various potential hot spots some of
which have already exploded is there are
places in northern india and possibly
places like central valley california
where very poor people who live on the
land and produce a lot of our food are
very susceptible to dry conditions
and the first thing you might think of
doing is irrigating but that gets to be
expensive i work with jeff sax a little
bit on a sub-saharan africa
project and the models will show that
with irrigation you could actually
increase farm incomes and farm output in
the sub-saharan region but factoring in
real constraints on the amount of funds
available and expertise available turns
out only about five to ten percent of
that potential could be
observed in the aquifer case the big
problem has been without knowing exactly
how much
groundwater was there non-sustainable so
sometimes called fossil water those were
being depleted as a coping mechanism
while it was
impossible to cope with warmer
temperatures by irrigating
and unfortunately with better
measurement techniques it now looks like
some of these aquifers are close to
collapsing completely so there's there
was this unfortunate
incident about four or five years ago
again in this very uh fertile but very
dry
region of india where
even before the crop returns came in
there were about 25 or 30
farmers who committed suicide because
things look so bad i think we're likely
to see this around the world on the
happy face side of this i was glad to
hear tom's kind of solution space since
about 2015 there's been a tremendous
amount of interest in analysis
in what happens if you look at both
climate goals on the one hand and un
sustainable development goals
interestingly made quantitative in a
very forceful way almost the same time
as the paris accord was signed and in
that analyses we see certain no-brainer
synergies where if you recruit reduce
coal combustion without control you're
creating a lot of particles and really
bad air pollution previously discussed
here and exacerbating climate change on
balance so that's an easy positive one
in the water space the work i've seen
it's a mixed bag so you have to know
what you're doing and strategically do
this some of the solutions tom mentioned
i think are technological solutions that
could be giving us new win-win win-win
solutions to that so i think just
because there's a conflict in goals and
interest doesn't mean that you stop
there one thing i love about
entrepreneurs in issues like this is
that they keep the goals firmly in mind
and don't get too hung up on my way or
the highway we see various
groups of social scientists and
ethicists having very narrow conceptions
of what might solve these problems
sometimes in my view losing sight of the
ultimate goals and wanting their way to
be the right way to solve the problem so
i applaud and encourage state-of-the-art
entrepreneurs like tom to jump in there
and show us how things could be done in
a better way so i want to talk about
extreme events that have been tied to
climate change such as floods droughts
hurricanes tornadoes heat waves and how
these extreme events have resulted in
forced migration and affecting our basic
access to the resource i mentioned
shelter we saw what happened in texas a
few weeks ago with the rolling power
outages and just the prolonged blackout
that left
many citizens in the dark and cold how
do we prepare communities for these
extreme weather events especially as it
affects shelter you can prepare you can
harden
all of the energy generating equipment
that's out there most of the problem
during the recent ercot situation
was actually with liquid fuel they
didn't really have much of a problem
with renewables nothing no problem with
solar some problem with wind but nothing
that couldn't have been prevented if the
wind energy generating equipment would
have been
built in anticipation of more severe
weather events than had previously
existed so my sense is renewables showed
pretty well during this ercot period it
was actually the liquid fuels that had
the biggest
the most problems now of course there
were there's a regulatory issue and the
fact that texas had to have its own
regulations independent of other states
in in the union which uh didn't help i
think what many of us don't recognize is
how ill-prepared we were for this kind
of an event uh
that from what i understand
we were
five minutes away from total grid
shot down
in texas
and to this day
nobody knows how they would have
restarted there's complete
hands up in the air on that one
which is pretty amazing now
hopefully there'll be certain changes
before we have the next
snowfall in texas but
it precipitated a huge crisis and and
and a huge
issue of social justice that we have to
be very concerned about we
we have to be
we don't hear a lot about the grid but
the grid is
both a friend and foe at the same time
we
see the deleterious effects and what
happened in texas but we can
democratize the grid we can utilize the
grid so long as we have renewables
available we can get rid of liquid fuels
we can talk about
electrons once we have electrons to do
our work
then the whole world changes and it's in
fact there's a institute
that ruined magendar started at stanford
called bits and watts that's actually
working on this problem they're doing
some really good work on
both
but not just the grid it's the
information cloud as well we need to
make infrastructure improvements
that will put us back on track in terms
of our ability to grow gmp gmp has
declined since 2008 from
pretty much linear path that had been on
before we're not adding gnp at the same
rate that we were
and part of that is that we
don't have the infrastructure that
enables us to
apply technology to our benefit a great
example of that is that there are 47
million people in this country that do
not have access to the broadband
information cloud during covet there
were almost equal number of people whose
internet service was shut down for
non-payment
there was almost 100 million people in
this country that did not have access to
broadband internet that is crazy that
would not be a hugely expensive
infrastructure
investment
considering how much we're now
having to invest for the consequences of
code and other misadventures clearly
these problems are solvable and that's
what gets me so frustrated because
people are not thinking
the full dimension it's not just about
renewables it's about
upstream downstream electrons and how we
use electrons and and how we take
advantage of
all this unbelievable technology that's
been created in the last year john
question for you is tom alluded to our
infrastructure in the u.s um just isn't
sustainable long term so building on
tom's comments what do you think we need
and should do to upgrade our
infrastructure in the us i think as
we'll probably see in the current
administration just to be more
aggressive at the policy level and
either investing directly or creating
instead of the private sector to do so
historically we haven't been too bad on
that we did build the interstate highway
system we did build the
natural gas pipeline network and a bunch
of other things historically we seem to
have a political difficulty in making
any investments that might pay off for
over a long
period of time arguing more about
immediate gratification if i could put
it that way
i do think the youngsters here your
generation has
the ability to influence such things
because the the impacts of climate
change are now more obvious to everyone
we have better
data abilities monitor we've been
risen i hate to use a trait word to the
social just social and environmental
justice issues that will likely dominate
actual decision making so since i got
out of hardcore engineering about 1980
i've spent most of my time on social
sciences first following economics and
systems analysis and a
few other things and then later into
political science and social sciences in
a way i never thought i would as
many of the precord energy efficiency
center we did jim sweeney the my boss at
that point brought together computer
scientists with behavioralists and tried
to design these i think tom was
referring to what we now call behavioral
nudges so 20 years ago economists said
behavior is second order we're not going
to waste our time or our faculty
thoughts on such people now every
major econ top 20 econ department in the
country is looking for their second or
third or more
behavioral economist being totally
shameless about saying something they
thought previously wasn't important and
probably didn't exist to saying it's now
part of our discipline but that's okay
again we don't want to fight about who's
got the best ideas we want to take all
the all the
available ideas so i am somewhat
optimistic we can manage these
basically institutional and social
constraints a lot better than we have a
lot of it has to do with what people
have called in the justice community and
so forth transparency democracy does not
work as well as we might hope if there
is not
transparency so i think we got into this
greatest generation paradigm which was
good i've talked i fortunately got to
talk to george sults before we lost him
about this his generation said what we
need around the world is democracy that
leads to greater transparency which
leads to market economies which leads to
perfect markets which leads to
ideal perfectly efficient solutions and
a lot of that train uh was true for a
while now i think we're realizing that
not all
uh agents and markets tom already
mentioned one big company i could
mention several others uh actually are
doing things in a way that's perfectly
competitive nor do they internalize what
we now call so
so good we now see
not just the financial community getting
into the climate game in a way they
didn't up until 10 years ago but more
recently major it firms i've been amazed
that jeff bezos is trying to play
catch-up and has a major sustainability
initiative first a set of pilot projects
here at stanford now probably going to
be a major new
initiative alongside google and apple
and all the rest thanks john so we
talked about so far four main resources
that are essential for human survival
food water air and shelter and of course
tom added and reminded me of another one
energy i have a few questions on that at
a very high level of course we need
clean efficient and affordable
energy systems and that's been a big
need that startups and investors have
worked to tackle tom how has investing
in energy systems today differed from
when you were inactive in the first wave
of clean tech investing in silicon
valley around 2008. yeah it's changed
dramatically clearly the energy industry
i believe reached its peak in the 1970s
1970s resources were came partially due
to the
oil crisis that took place in the 70s
it started to turn people
ahead to our dependency on oil and gas
and how harmful that is not only from a
climate perspective
but from a resources perspective
spending
trillions of dollars to
defend
the oil resources in the persian gulf
during the world war
i don't think that was a very use of our
capital
and yet
we were we've been so consumed by oil
and gas and believed i worked for exxon
i i know something about the oil and gas
business and
certainly the industrialization
associated with uh coal and oil and gas
proceeded from 1750 to today encouraged
a lot of progress for humankind but
we're paying one hell of a price for it
the good news is we don't need oil and
gas anymore we can make everything we've
previously made from oil and gas we can
including energy we can make it from
renewables we can make
synthetic biology these things will
happen and i believe that decreasing our
dependence on oil and gas is certainly
can only have positive consequences for
humankind in almost every way and what's
going on
now is the transition fortunately we
have a government that has
some consciousness about the opportunity
to switch over to renewables and the
consequences of that that will help but
the other thing that's happened is that
these major resources of energy
food
water
available to us now cost
that is far less than ever and
it's declining every day solar is
essentially free at this point
and that's what enables source global to
make their purified water and
solar plus is actually a major theme of
our investment practice how do you apply
solar
to do all kinds of things not just
electrons what is in the impact on
non-carbon fuels we we haven't talked
about hydrogen but there's tremendous
opportunity for us with low-cost
hydrogen there are issues of course
there's always dishes but they're not
impossible
on the one hand
optimistic and the other very impatient
and but i
we're over the hurdle all these
issues
that we think about are all about
manufacturing cost curves and price
elasticity of demand and
we've overcome
the the mathematics of scale in
renewables and we can put it to work now
to totally take care of carbon problem
but it's not just
the issue that's not
to it's not only to stop contaminating
the atmosphere with carbon but get rid
of the carbon that we've already dumped
in the atmosphere and
i think
the area that i see most promising is in
regenerative agriculture
means of mineral mineralizing co2 in the
form of carbonates and other minerals
things like olivine you know it's
creating value from the carbon dioxide
not just paying
somebody a hundred dollars a ton or
actually which is i think fiction
probably more like a thousand dollars a
ton
for direct air capture or air capture in
general i do believe that we have a
great opportunity now that we've done
this scaling we have free solar and we
can put it to work optimistic and
inpatient indeed
john question for you regarding policy
and the biden administration biden has
stated a pretty bold climate vision
we've not pulled enough um to reach net
zero emissions by 2050
and also to achieve zero carbon
electricity by 2035.
what predictions do you have on what his
administration will actually do and how
will this affect investments in the
sector i would say from what i can tell
there's a great mobilization going on a
lot of the great people and advisors
like tom have been brought back in
immediately even before the inauguration
even before the election as the odds
seem to be going one one particular way
i think there'll be a
very big renaissance as we learned from
the book we did together a lot of these
people went through the early 2000s
clean tech 1.0 an hour and then came
back for the obama administration and
made much more substantial
impact through things like the
establishment of rpe and a number of
other things and i think this time the
time is even uh riper now than before so
i think we will see a lot of action now
institutionally
probably most of you didn't know what an
executive order was before obama and a
lot of you before trump if that's the
way it needs to get started it'll get
started the congress will come around i
predict if those things start being
successful because they'll then want to
take credit uh for saving the world and
doing so in a low cost a business green
business friendly way moderately to very
optimistic i'm a regalian philosopher so
i think the way we learn how to do
things particularly when we have to move
fast
is creating a meritocracy where
everybody's ideas are heard and absorbed
and then
somebody with some political will and
know-how makes the makes the final
decision so i'm optimistic that's what
we're going to see my cause for more
optimism now than say even when obama
came in is thanks to people like tom the
technology base is better thanks to a
lot of research people have done we know
more about what they're doing and
finally because of young people like you
those of you in this class i think that
may be
ultimately the biggest and most
important resource that we can tap into
as we move ahead with you and your
national and uh international networks
of various sorts thanks yeah we actually
uh just want one comment on that we
actually spent a few months trying to
classify
the magnitude of the opportunity that we
have
as a result of
the pioneering work that was done in the
first cleantech
program
see old story pioneers always end up
with arrows in their backs
but the fact is that we've ended up as a
society with scaled
technologies that can deal with a lot of
our problems we just have to go about it
in a very orderly way
recognizing all the dimensions all of
the vectors among regulatory technology
and financial that are required
to
bring this movement home and i th
our attempt to quantify the up
opportunity
resulted in
we estimate that the energy
transformation that will take place
globally over the next 10 to 20 years
will engender
opportunities in the range from 1 to 10
trillion dollars one of the reasons why
esg investing has become so interesting
because there's
an opportunity to make money via this
transformation not only by building gnp
but also
very simply
replacing obsolete infrastructure thank
you both for paving the way early on i
wanted to turn to some questions from
the class one of the questions is how do
we incentivize all countries to
collaborate together on sustainability
especially given game theory maybe the
student who asked it could add some
additional commentary hi everyone i also
want to ask the question so i think the
question here is just about how do you
get countries to work together because i
feel like it's a global problem like
each country produces its own greenhouse
gases it uses different type of energy
but at the same time i like developing
countries are saying that hey the rich
countries got rich by destroying the
environment we need to grow first before
we can protect the environment and then
there were also cases where you know
trump someone like trump could
unilaterally decide to pull the us out
of the paris agreement so the question
is about how do we bring
everyone in the world together to align
on some of these very global problems
yeah capitalism is certainly a great
motivation and the opportunity of the
magnitude that i described
one to ten trillion dollars a year
certainly ought to attract a lot of
people to come together and work on this
but it's also an issue of survival i
think about my grandchildren i think
about what kind of world they're going
to face
if we let carbon run up into the 450
plus parts per million it's not going to
be fun at the same time the phrase i
love is
doing well by doing good i believe it's
as simple as that it's in
everyone's interest to do well by doing
good to
make sure that the
they work in
collaborative means some of which can is
going to have accumulated by regulatory
some of these
functions are going to have to be forced
to come together and legislation is
probably the best way to do that at
least in a democratic society like we
have here but you're absolutely correct
we have to appeal to people's sense of
greed or sense of justice
to
be willing
come together in a movement
that will affect the kind of change that
we need to see these have to be
from it's almost like the way i think
about like a software stack so you have
these vectors of
regulatory
financial technology and then you have
networks
among these vectors it's those networks
that have to
smooth
that
stacking function that
really are required one other question
from the class maybe for inspiration
what are some countries that have done a
good job in addressing some of the
resource problems we discussed around
air food water shelter energy and
specifically what can we learn from them
who asked that question that was me as
well
yeah i think it was just like i think
different countries have different ways
of solving it what are some maybe like
centers of excellence around the
different types of sustainability
whether it's around food water and so on
that that we can learn from i'm from
singapore originally so i know that we
have a lot of issues with trying to
secure like food and water security and
i think we've done a couple of things
for example like desalinating sea water
but also processing urine so that we can
get good drinking water but but i think
i was just and also i think some of our
classmates are from israel i spent a
good amount of time there as well and i
think they've done some of these
questions well but i was hoping to also
hear from the professors and the experts
here on what else are stories that we
can learn from other countries well i
think those are two pretty good examples
you mentioned singapore and israel maybe
even better is a little country called
bhutan utah where they actually have a
constitution that says they should
pursue happiness and sustainability
explicitly so maybe not all the
countries could scale up to their level
but the idea of reconsidering i think
tom really touched on this what the heck
are we doing and what are our goals
individually and collectively
particularly collectively again back to
your other problem there are a group who
have studied a group of people who've
studied the problems that you identified
the free rider problem and actually for
me observing the un process is in many
u.n processes it's a great place for
countries to come vet and express their
frustration and what their interests are
i think a lot of this necessarily needs
to get worked out from the bottom up
because different countries are so
heterogeneous it's hard to get a kind of
a monolithic solution i i personally
think paris although it's not legally
binding which was the original goal for
the framework convention was a big step
forward because it got all countries
engaged in doing what they could from
their own perspective i think within the
major emitting countries obviously
germany has done better better than most
i worked a lot with japan japan was
already pretty efficient and now
straining to get even in the aftermath
of fukushima trying to get more
efficient so i think there are
examples out there again i like in that
the entrepreneurial version of this
where i personally think development
planning would have been a lot better
off globally
if we took it out of the hands of the
economists who had wonderful theories
that looked good on paper and didn't
work in practice so i think having
entrepreneurs go to each and every
country and say okay i understand the
damn theory but here we are looking at
people in the face and seeing what
they are interested in wanting to do
let's improvise and let help them
achieve their goals through technology
or new business models or what i call
institutional what many people now call
institutional entrepreneurship
so i just think we have to be more bold
and think globally again and act locally
and build up again what i see in the
political frame is if you do something
that's a little bit far out and it turns
out to be successful the policy makers
will be happy to help you do that so the
policymakers may not want to do a
thousand dollar or a hundred or two
hundred dollar carbon tax but if you get
them close enough to say given our
bottom-up activities we can make the
market a bit more efficient with a much
smaller carbon tax or other types of
incentives i think they'll probably do
it and take credit for it but that's
again that's a good thing because then
everybody will be on the same page
finally thanks john tom any final
thoughts for today's class
all right
my one comment i could make is i i
really what elon musk has done
with his uh 100 million dollar x prize
for carbon removal he is absolutely
picked up on the concept of
not only do we need to deal with carbon
emissions but we need to deal with
carbon restoration that is we need to
perhaps
get back to
pre-industrial levels of carbon
has
350 parts per million perhaps but it's
the
point is that he wants to make an impact
on
carbon neutrality but also carbon
negativity
that's what we have to keep in mind i i
think many of the
uh ideas that are out there right now
are just not aggressive enough